stand from delving deeper into linda
Anderson's story what's your takeaway on
her life whether you consider her the
victim the victimizer I think she's both
I think Linda Anderson which is what
makes the movie interesting is both the
victim and the villain as a parent
myself that's what drew me to the
material is that kind of gray area that
everybody lives in in this movie there
are no heroes there are no villains
everybody lives in kind of that place
between being a hero and being a villain
and I was kind of interested to see if I
could keep the audience from feeling one
way or the other somebody wearing a
black hat or a white hat and Linda
Anderson I think tries hard but makes
them very very very big mistakes in
creating a home life for girls that lead
them to a place where they think there's
only one way out right and you do keep
her somewhat likable definitely
throughout the film and I love how you
have the fantasy mom image throughout I
think that's great which brings me to my
next question as you mentioned you know
you were drawn to the story but you're a
producer for 30 years what was your
decision now to go and be the director
of this film I had made so many movies
and had reached kind of the pinnacle
after winning an Emmy and being
nominated multiple times and I really
wanted to try and direct and see if I
could do it after all this time after
complaining about directors that have
worked for me and so decided finally to
take that shot and it was this piece of
material that I'd originally developed
as a television movie that was just far
too dark to make and so I put it on the
shelf and but it always kind of nagged
at me and I felt like it was the most
compelling story I knew out there that I
could make at a price and get my first
shot well looking at your bio I know
that you have a passion for bringing a
voice to people that are you know
physically or mentally challenged so in
what sense were you bringing a voice to
Linda's story who was also marginalized
in our own way she's a single mother
facing facing addiction well I think
everybody in this is a victim I think
Linda's a victim I think the girls are
victims I think the little boy is a
victim and I think there's a lot of
guilt to go around for how the girls
ended up in this situation and I wanted
to see if I could make the story
pathetic and not just sort of what you
read in the headlines not okay well this
this woman was a bad mom and so these
bad girls did this bad thing I wanted to
see if I could make it much more
compelling than so make everyone have a
reason for their life having reason for
their choices and hopefully understand
them if not sympathize with them mm-hmm
now you've lasted in this business for
so long what's been the secret to that
because I'm sure there's good times and
bad I bad how have you been able to
sustain it's not an easy business I've
always come from a place I've wanted to
tell good stories and I think that's
that I've never chased ratings I've
never chased box office I've really only
been inspired by stories and if the
story inspires me I try and sell it and
I think that sort of been my my luck and
staying around and being able to make
three or four movies a year for the last
20 years and and stay somewhere relevant
is that I'm always interested in telling
a good story I also was you know
mesmerised by the work of people like
Billy Wilder & John Ford and preston
sturges and I think if you watch the
older movies there's a lot to learn and
part of why I wanted to direct let's see
if I could take some of those lessons
and put them into a contemporary setting
great all right thank you